in this video I want to talk about
allosteric regulation of the glycolytic
enzymes so we talked about the three
enzymes that needed to be allosteric we
regulated in glycolysis hexokinase
phosphofructokinase 1 and pyruvate
kinase and the reason why is because all
three of those enzymes catalyze
irreversible steps whereas all the other
enzymes in glycolysis can be used to
catalyze the reverse step which is part
of the gluconeogenic pathway which I'll
talk about in a later video so let's
let's go through and see what each one
of these allosteric effectors is for
these different enzymes kind of if they
make sense or not so hexokinase has one
allosteric effector and that's g6p so
high levels of g6p inhibit hexokinase
from functioning well Hextall kinase
creates it what it does is it takes
glucose and turns it into g6p so it
doesn't make sense that g6p would
inhibit XO kinase yeah it makes sense
because g6p is the end product all right
so essentially what's going on here is a
form of negative feedback so that
negative feedback there basically that's
just g6p saying there's plenty of me
don't make more of me so don't don't
make more if plenty okay that's it for
Nexo kinase just has that one allosteric
effector and it's one allosteric
effector is an inhibitor now phosphor
two kinase we said was the first
committed step right actually let's
write that in red that's pretty
important so this is the first committed
step alright so because it's the first
committed step after this after this
step occurs we've committed to
glycolysis this thing cruises f-16 BP
which is for toast 1 6 bisphosphate that
molecule is committed to the pathway
glycolysis so it's going to be highly
regulated as you can see here it has a
bunch of different allosteric effectors
the first one that we're going to talk
about is the other ones that inhibit it
so high levels of ATP inhibit push patro
phosphofructokinase why would that
happen well high levels of ATP what does
that really signal high levels of ATP
indicate
a high energy state so basically there's
a lot of ATP around that means we have
plenty of energy phosphofructokinase
commits to glycolysis and one of the
products of glycolysis is of course ATP
so basically we want to commit to
glycolysis when we want to create energy
there's already plenty of an energy
around don't make more so if we indicate
if there's a high energy state there's
plenty of energy don't make more so
don't make more so that makes sense
right there's a high energy state
there's no need to commit to making more
energy no need to commit to oops to
making more energy cool
now why would high levels of phospho you
know pyruvate or PEP inhibit fossil
fordo kinase well PEP comes later in the
in the pathway of glycolysis and
basically if there's a lot of if there's
a buildup of it that probably means that
the step that goes from PEP to pyrrha to
via pyruvate kinase to pyruvate is not
happening if that's not happening we
don't want to keep creating PEP
so basically PEP if it builds up it'll
tell phosphofructokinase don't make more
of me okay so it's telling foster from 2
kinase stop creating me there's plenty
of me already around right so it's sort
of the same reason as as we mentioned
here there's no need to make more of
plenty now there are a few things that
activate phosphofructokinase 1 the the
committed step awake Hollis's so
phosphofructokinase is activated by high
levels of ADP and high levels of a.m. P
now both of these things you can kind of
imagine when does ADP come into play ADP
results after we've used up ATP and a.m.
P could even result that of that same
way
in any case high levels of ADP and a MP
they kind of do the opposite of high
of ATP they indicate low energy states
so if they indicate low energy states
then we want to commit to making more
energy so if we have low energy those
Leonard a lot of those low energy a lot
of those indicators of low energies we
want to make sure that those things
activate the production of more energy
phosphor de kinase commits to making
more energy so it makes sense that these
indicators of low energy would would
want us to commit to making more so
commit to making more energy last thing
here high levels of fructose to 6
bisphosphate or f to 6 BP i'll also
activate phosphor do kinase one this
one's a little bit fishy little bit
tough to understand and if you recall
some of you may have seen that other
video that i made a bit complex i wanted
to simplify things here for toes to 6
bisphosphate is made by
phosphofructokinase to write foster 2
kinase 1 makes fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
the thing the molecule that's committed
to glycolysis fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
is made by PF k 2 now that thing as i
mentioned in that other video if you saw
it is hormonal ii controlled so the
hormones that control it are insulin and
glucagon which we'll talk more about
later in future videos but i don't want
to dwell too much on that right now
instead the reasoning behind this just
kind of keep it at this simple idea that
a lot of this being around this is an
indicator of this indicates a high
glucose availability so if there's a
joseph' available we want to decrease
that amount of glucose right so we have
a large concentration of glucose logical
availability then we want to break that
glucose down or reduce that amount okay
so we reduce that amount lower that
amount that glucose concentration by by
activating glycolysis right and
specifically by activating the committed
step of glycolysis right
phosphofructokinase one okay so that's
essentially what's going on there so
there's a high amount of 4 to 6
bisphosphate that indicates a high
amount of glucose available if there's a
high amount of glucose available when
I'll lower it so we're going to lower
that Google amount by activating my
calluses breaking it down to pyruvate so
we want to commit to that pathway okay
and again let me mention here just just
briefly the hormones that are actually
controlled it are glucagon and insulin
and glucagon is the hormone that
increases blood glucose levels whereas
insulin is the one that decreases blood
glucose levels so between these two
which one would activate pfk to glucagon
is the thing that increased blood
glucose levels here we're trying to a
decrease blood glucose levels so this
one would deactivate pfk 2 whereas
insulin would activate pfk 2 because
it's the one that wants to decrease the
blood glucose levels so insulin wouldn't
play a role in in activating glycolysis
sort of through this mechanism okay this
this bit isn't all too crazy important
for this explanation as long as you
understand that the high levels of
fructose to six best phosphate indicate
this high amount of glucose and we want
to lower that so we'll activate
glycolysis by activating the committed
step ok so now let's get into pyruvate
kinase so pyruvate kinase has three
different allosteric inhibitors those
are high levels of ATP so high levels of
ATP what I'm going to write here
just the same as above right same as
above and what I mean by that is that if
there's plenty it indicates plenty of
energy if there's plenty of energy
around there's no need to creat creating
more for this pyruvate kinase step makes
that last bit of ATP we don't want that
to be active group if we already have
plenty of ATP around
so now let's mention acetyl co a why
would a lot of acetyl co away inhibit
pyruvate kinase well if there's a lot of
acetyl co a this is also an indicator of
having plenty of energy um so I'm gonna
actually write that here also indicates
plenty of energy but um which which
would you know sort of lead into why
we'd have to stop like ala sis right
inhibit glycolysis um in addition if
there's a bunch of acetyl co a that
probably means that the TCA cycle which
actually uses up acetyl co a and breaks
it down to create a bunch of nadh s for
the electron transport chain is backed
up it's also so it also indicates the
family of energy but so that's like the
first thing that it does or one of the
things that it does the second thing is
that it also indicates the TCA is backed
up to some extent right that these these
acetyl co ways are not being used up so
there's no sense in creating more
pyruvate which might actually be turned
into acetyl co way if there's already
plenty of acetyl co way around right so
this is also why we want to stop
creating pyruvate because that pyruvate
is often going to turn into a seed okay
it's a little bit fishy now but it will
sort of make more sense later hopefully
so what about high amounts of alanine if
you recall alanine is an amino acid it's
actually a derivative of pyruvate okay
so this is a derivative of pyruvate and
I'll kind of show you guys how that the
Kate how that is just a second so it's a
derivative of pyruvate so it indicates
high levels of pi root
right just high levels of pyruvate
there's no sense in making more right so
if this is a high level a priori wait
don't make more so how does that even
make sense well let's think about this
what do we know alanine to look like it
looks like an amino acid it has this
carboxyl group here this hydrogen here
and amino group here and a ch3 here well
how does pyruvate look pyruvate looks
like this and that's how pyruvate looks
so this is alanine and this is pyruvate
they look very very similar the only
difference here is this alpha carbon has
this alpha carbon and alanine has the
amino group of hydrogen whereas in
pyruvate we just have that that ketone
that carbonyl group there so that's
there they're very very similar in
structure so if there's a lot of alanine
around that indicates high levels of
pyruvate which we want to inhibit in the
production of more pyruvate last bit
here this act of this fructose 1 6
bisphosphate high levels of that
activate pyruvate kinase this
essentially means if there's a lot of
this around this means that the
committed step is very being very
productive so this means the committed
step committed step right the pfk step
is being very productive right so we're
committing to glycolysis a great deal
what we don't want we don't want to get
to phosphoenolpyruvate and then get to
this part of a kinase step and have it
not be able to go through if we're
committing to glycolysis we want to make
sure that we finished glycolysis so it
would make sense then that high levels
of the committed molecule would activate
the completion of glycolysis ok so I
hope that was helpful in clearing things
up as far as allosteric regulation of
glycolysis see in the next video